the Prime Minister of Slovakia Peter  Pellegrini is the speaker at this week's  future of Europe debate MEP s vote on  measures to protect Internet users from  disinformation campaigns in the European  elections in May they want to introduce  financial penalties for EU parties which  break data protection rules to influence  the vote Parliament set to approve new  measures including better protection for  consumers easier procedures for  businesses and more power to the EU  cybersecurity agency the new solidarity  core will give young people more  opportunities to volunteer changes  include the possibility to participate  in humanitarian actions outside the EU  and more guidance for youth who need  support Parliament votes on rules to  improve everyday products and services  for the disabled from cash machines to  mobile phones MEP s want better access  for the 80 million disabled Europeans  [Music]